this is why Meghan Markle only wore
muted colors during her early days as a
royal she explained her beige wardrobe
as an intentional Choice saying to my
understanding you can't ever wear the
same color as her majesty if there's a
group event but then you also shouldn't
wear the same color as some of the other
more senior members of the family so I
was like well what's the color that
they'll probably never wear camel beige
white so I wore a lot of muted tones but
it was also so I could just blend in she
continued I'm not trying to stand out
here there's no version of me joining
this family and trying not to do
everything I could to fit in however her
brief time as a senior Royal saw her
come out of her shell a little more
making Bolder choices that we'll use for
inspo for the rest of our days